jake hi how are you
hi katie good to see you it's good to
see you i'm so excited for this fight
it's august 29th you're going into this
undefeated
3-0 it's in your hometown
what is this what does this mean to you
it means everything you know i think
this is uh this is the make or break
fight right this is where people get to
see
you know is jake paul serious or not
this is my toughest opponent to date
and getting to fight in cleveland my
hometown in front of friends and family
it's a dream come true we get to bring
it home where
where i was born where it all started
when i first started playing sports
uh so i couldn't be couldn't be more
excited
three is a obviously perfect record but
some
say there's no way that you can stay
undefeated
what do you say to those people and how
have you kind of trained
differently for this the those people i
say
you know i've sparred hundreds of hours
now
and have barely lost a round in sparring
so you know how how am i uh how am i
gonna lose fight
and that's i think really where my my
confidence comes from is the
level of competition i'm going against
in sparring
and really pushing myself um and
the the haters fuel me you know they
have my whole entire career everyone's
doubted me
i've been a massive underdog the whole
entire time people tell me i can't do
things and
all it's done is driven me and gave me
so much motivation
if i beat you you have to get i love
jake paul tattooed on you
but but if you beat me i get i love
tyrone woodley tattooed on me and you
have to post it on your instagram feed
deal or no deal i just saw the tattoo
exchange you said that you'll get
tyron's name tattooed on you if you lose
and
and he'll get your name tattooed will
that actually
happen i mean we shook on it
so when he loses you know we'll see if
he's a man of his word
he's supposed to post it on his
instagram feed so i i guess
i guess we'll see that you know the
stakes have increased
you're an ep of this event i think for
the first time right
what does that mean for your involvement
here are the stakes
higher is it fair that you're an ep of
this
yeah look um you know it's just business
at the end of the day and you know being
involved uh
from all angles on the event to make it
the best product possible
i want fans to enjoy this experience and
i want
to bring something to boxing that hasn't
been done before and
put on amazing events um and so that's
that's really my goal
and showtime is the perfect partner to
do that
and you know a lot of fighters the goal
is to have their own promotion company
and i'm doing that
in just my fourth fight tyron did say in
a press release quote
i don't play games with kids they
brought me in to take the trash out
you're welcome how do you respond to
that
look the guy can say whatever he wants
you know we're selling a fight he's
going to talk his
i'm going to talk my but at the end of
the day the actions speak louder than
the words
no one's going to remember what the [ __ ]
talk was before the fight
so august 29th you know i plan on
putting on a violent
show and and knocking this guy out and
that's what people
will remember um and
i'm all for the talk and uh we're
selling tape reviews
yeah i feel like you've been an underdog
you called yourself
an underdog yet you are threo is it hard
i guess to sort of prove yourself
in this boxing world and to hear
comments like this
about yourself you know i i don't i
don't really care
what what people think i i think
everyone's always gonna have an opinion
the critics are always gonna doubt you
so you know you can't pay attention to
that all that noise
it's not healthy i appreciate that you
don't let people's comments about you
get to you but there was a lot of
chatter
last year when you called covid19
a hoax i guess i'm curious if you've
changed your stance
on that if you're vaccinated now how
you've
handled the pandemic i just want to
like to answer that question do you feel
like your
your words have a lot of weight like do
you feel like you should be cautious
with what you say uh of course
you know we're all humans i'm gonna make
mistakes
so it's natural i think celebrities are
criticized and cancelled all the time
now
but people forget that you know we're
humans we're all humans just learning
how do you feel about cancer culture
uh i think it's stupid i think people
are canceling cancer culture
you know when you when you're canceling
someone all you're doing is making them
more popular
and giving them a bigger platform if you
don't like somebody don't talk about
them
you also made headlines last year when
the fbi
raided your house i think they
confiscated they did
it was all over the news so i guess i'm
asking you what really happened there i
feel like
i want to give you the opportunity i
don't remember that just that you don't
remember when the
fbi led allegedly raided your house
right i don't remember that
happening okay you remember i don't know
anything you want to say to set the
record straight
about what about the fbi raiding your
house about
looting potentially allegedly
i uh i don't have anything to say about
something that didn't happen
okay well let's talk about the boxing
documentary for a second
what will that show us about you that we
haven't seen before what's a side of you
that you haven't put out there
yet well i think you know my career has
been
painted uh by the media and so
everything that's out there about jake
paul is
a painting that i didn't create i think
the documentary will show a completely
different side of my life who i am what
my intentions are
people look at me as a uh a bad guy a
villain a crazy
you know youtuber who did all of these
things
um but that that's not the reality of
the situation and
everyone everyone has their own story to
tell in their own version of the way
things happened and
i've just learned not to judge a book by
its cover and i think
people haven't read the jake paul book
yet they don't know me they don't know
they think they know me but they
actually don't what do we get
wrong what's the biggest i guess
misconception that you are wanting to
set
straight i i think just in general
like being being like problematic
they think controversy they think like
oh you know
jake paul because that was like a big
big thing that was that was
going back and forth you know in the old
days but i'm i'm just a kid you know
living my life uh and it's under a
microscope
and so imagine if you know all of us
lived our lives from 17 to 24 years old
on camera
you know what what things would have
been exposed about all of us
if there was millions of people watching
you grow up
it's it's easy to judge people it's it's
easy to
you know see the bad in people but like
i said like i'm a good person i know
that at the end of the day
i know you're a good person i've talked
to you a lot over the years but
you do you go by the name problem child
in the boxing world so do you feel like
you give in to it a little bit
this well that stems from like i i'm a
problem to deal with
in the ring you know i turn in i turn
into a different person
when i'm fighting you know it's like
jake paul and the problem child are
two different two different people i
flip a switch
you know i could be a nice person i
don't want confrontation in the streets
i'm
chill like people can say something i'm
like i don't really care
but when i'm in the ring i'm i'm there
to kill